tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fatti j
oggi siamo su ali ed isole shaun ragazzi
allora prima di cominciare
quello fare una piccolissima premessa
volevo ringraziare di cuore la casa di
produzione di questo videogame che alle
isole c'è un ragazzino sto aspettando da
da un secolo ha praticamente da più di
un anno che lo aspetto in teoria esce la
settimana prossima
che cazzo è successo non è partito
almeno a sé sega fatti una sega uscirà
la settimana prossima ragazzi me l'hanno
data in anteprima per poterlo giocare
per voi praticamente è un'esclusiva
mondiale no per un'esclusiva almeno
italiana saremo in primi ragazzi ad
immergerci questa bellissima avventura
piena di pony e voglio prima in the
entrare nell'atmosfera horror a tutti
gli effetti
facciamo medio dai così giusto per non
essere stupidi sinceramente ragazzi ho
paura di vedere di cosa si tratta perché
ho visto solo nei gameplay nel trailer
però sega presence non sono io che sono
pervertito la rivolta che la regola del
veicolo spaziali commerciali nostrano
nostromo gli altri componenti
dell'equipaggio che in esso sono morti
no no ciò significa che poche poche ma
non andrà più avanti ragazzi parla
ripley uniche superstiti del nostromo
passo e chiudo
[Musica]
workshop shabak la madonna è che cos'è
mica che partenza potente madonna al
cinema io l'ho mai fatto un gioco così
fatto da dio
questo merita di tutto che è una
cinematica pronta più mi piace è fatta
male la grafica il suo gioco milito
sarcasmo sono somewhere spiacerà favero
per la compagnia estate a non se le
ragazze di sedici 83 dell'amico se
intendono tratta di tua madre crediamo
di averla trovata ha mandato un vascello
commerciale la nemesi dora recuperato
una scatola nera che proviene
probabilmente dallo strappo c'è una nave
corriera chiamata torrens che andrà alla
stazione fra due giorni ci recheremo lì
sì io e un altro dirigente e tu se
vorrei io consiglierei di no poi fa il
cazzo che vuoi e zia non so giusto
perché c'è un soggetto presentimento ok
quando mi hanno affidato questo caso ho
fatto le mie ricerche so perché stai
lavorando nella regione in cui è
scomparsa tua madre ma starà cercando la
cerchi ancora vengono un genio mi è
stato dato il via libera per offrirti un
posto sulla torre
se vuoi venire io non andrei ragazzi
giusto perché ciò sto presentimento di
merda però ok come non detto chiama
cinematica più bella mi ha mai visto
cioè è una roba pazzesca dove siamo tra
l'altro adesso c'è io non ho capito
saranno già in una navicella oppure se
che apre a come l'idea iniziale andata
[ __ ] ci siamo adesso sulla navicella
perfetto siamo solo a torrens quella che
diceva prima io sono è la madonna è che
cos'è mio meglio meglio di britney
spears ragazzi mi sono svegliato ma ci
aveva un conto in sospeso con le
ciabatte mi stavano sul culo quindi non
a franco perfetto razzismo nei confronti
delle ciabatte che lo voglio subito
comunque ragazzi siamo sulla torrens
perché dovevo andare sulla navicella
preso si min
ah ok esplora thorens perfetta
fantastico story comoda zia mi chiama io
del mio letto qualcosa secondo me poi
non lo so perché non ho capito di qua si
può ha permesso ori burtone sino a
questo nome lo metto manco semi
piuttosto giro nudo e fante già mi piace
usa che cazzo è una donna
ecco lo sapevo che erano dati da vida
come dai fan culo la doccia perché si
spegne non ora quando spegniamo che non
si spreca nulla quindi si va vestiti
avrebbe trovati lo trovate davvero nome
preferito girare nuda sinceramente però
va bene anche così elevato di precisare
nuovo lì ci fa volli devo tornare sul
ponte ancora non ho capito pezzi di
metallo sensore colla prega mi spiegate
perchè cosa mi serve della colla in un
gioco così devo fare altro tac non ho
capito bello il ponte nicchia tipo
enterprise non fantastico io non ho mai
visto la gara una cosa così a figlia
tipo mi ricorda troppo dead space provi
credo se ancora più bello io posso fare
qualcosa tipo fare gli scherzi al
telefono
prendi il documento con le istruzioni
perfetto lavoro questo non lo so ma lo
voglio rendermi utile ragazzi sono
sembra raccogli le istruzioni o che
perfetto con queste lo faccio non dare
e la madonna mi chiami bellissimo basta
io mi sono innamorato di sto gioco
lasciamo a vederla ma se la sui monitor
ok succedere che amando interferenze
comunicazioni della stazione sono
disturbati no no non ditemi che ci state
andando a rega ok allora vorrei se può
rimanere in posizione per 24 ore
ti daremo notizie prima di luna ce
l'abbiamo tutti nel capra anzi lo sapete
rega non dobbiamo andare io non ci
andrei su quella cazzo di navicella poi
fate voi ma ce la prendiamo tutti nel
didietro convintissimo perfetto lega
tenetevi pronti per gli ultimi momenti
di tranquillità perché non ci sarà più
così tanto mobilità resta dietro di m
anche tu sai io scommetto che lui ci
voleva proprio rimanere dietro le stiamo
andando
di sicuro non l'hanno fatto benissimo
zia
è così che si vo la lega non è
fantastico abbiamo già nel culo partenza
[Musica]
che tipo
mio dio non ho mai litigato con tutti
bottino quello che ho sentito
sicché donna che ammazzava già morti
seria no non ci paga mica son già morti
sono stati sparati nello spazio tipo
gravi pietro non c'è questo credere sono
già ma perfetto monica sopra se non ci
sono già morti in parte nei grandissimi
haga due morti sono partiti in tre tempo
due minuti sono morti l'hai presa la
botta in testa di altri andata bene non
sei morta mica l'unica sopravvissuta ero
solito morto sono vivo ok posso alzarmi
brava sia brava perfetto sveglia che ci
sono le gocciole anche per dente siamo
nella nostra uomo che bel nome perfetto
ragazzi siamo salvi posso permesso
grazie mille cerca aiuto ma non c'è
nessuno qualche asso certo aiuto cambia
si toglie la tuta o cosa non capirsi si
è tolta tutto perfetto ragazzi adesso ce
l'abbiamo leggermente nel didietro
perché sono morti tutti tranne io
fantastico quindi la porta che sapete la
sola ne vogliamo parlare permesso sono
fa vj vengo in pace non hanno ama le
luci non si possono accendere così dove
non devono capirlo a sta cosa siamo pure
da soli tra trancio neanche armi quindi
il massimo della vita proprio
ok mamma è pronta a tavola ragazzo
proprio o si accendono le luci si
spengono devono decidersi perché non è
possibile votare non ho capito dove che
cazzo successo qualcuno non lo so però
non vado a controllare anzi torna
indietro e la festa ricomprato di
qualcuno accendiamo le candeline
ecco il birillo al birillo era un mio
nemico quindi l'ho ucciso io
possibilmente lontano da qui cos'è sta
roba usata ma posso fila viene condotto
no bellissimo sono sto strisciando nei
condotti tipo solid snake bellissimo sta
cosa non ha capito ancora che vengono
lui dovette capire che nei giochi horror
le luci non li dovete spegnere che non
le dovete spendo finisce male o lo dico
prega perché è diventato rosso
mio dio lucia è perfetto ma girato al
punto meraviglioso ragazzi chicca fatto
sono sti rumori frutti sono sentite
basta me ne vado
porca [ __ ] sono cascato meraviglioso
hai un futuro amica mia nel mondo del
circo credimi se vuoi veramente un
fenomeno sono anche ammazzato
leggermente bellissimo è stato
istruttivo molto bello questo ci insegna
ragazzi a non camminare su dei pezzi di
legno nelle navicelle che stanno per
esplodere molto è sconsigliato diciamo
moving continuo a muoverti va bene
grazie seguirò il tuo consiglio però
prima fammi salire la scala perché la
vedo tanto so che i ragazzi so che mi
spinge qualcuno non mi ha spinto nessuno
perché pensavo ci fosse uno mi spingesse
non è successo ancora niente fortunata
fortunatamente però usa come cazzo fai
sacino stereo no ma è una navicella
piena di vita ragazzi credetemi proprio
non vedevo l'ora di fare festa usa
questi terminali per aggiornare la mappa
con le aree la partita ecco questo devo
tirare scalea fantastico nel caso mi
serve totti lavora bene non ha tirato
una leva a caso rega non ho capito bene
che cosa serve accedi al terminale sia
acceso qualche ho acceso qualcosa che
non ho capito cosa ripristina la
corrente e lara partenza o che ci siamo
ok bridge a salve sono fa vj vengo in
pace sono proprio no niente manca gatto
di striscio
le casse sono andati no ha mai chiuso
dentro mica questa nella segno
[ __ ] a tutti devo andar via di qui
perché non me la gente è ospitale come
un dito nel deretano quindi ha fatto
bene andare ecco l'effetto di qua
security check point perfetto fantastica
apollo e all'elettricità ragazzi non
andiamo molto d'accordo se visto città è
bat hai rotto il cazzo perché sarò che
sta crollando a minchia space light
terminal ok non ha capito benissimo cosa
diavolo è successo qui secondo me hanno
avuto tutti un attacco d'arte improvvisa
però non ci giurerei troppo c'è quella è
la mia meta siccome sono rimasto
incastrato qua dentro
e quando ragazzi direi che posso
concludere qui il primo episodio anche
se non è ancora successo niente perché
deve ingranare il gioco ma è una figata
pazzesca non crea e fantastico poterlo
giocare proveniente prima una cosa io
non avrei mai immaginato di un gioco di
questo calibro soprattutto quindi
chiaramente non vedo l'ora di fare il
prossimo episodio mi chiami andata bene
non ci sono stati infatti eccessivi in
questo preparatevi per i prossimi lega
perché non sarà con successo io spero
che sarà comunque casse il video vi è
piaciuto la seta lasciato commenti mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook e come
noi video tratte una descrizione se
vorresti di scriveteli ci rivediamo nel
prossimo video belle ragazze